30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
welcome back to another workout today's
session will be working on your core as
well as your cardio so we want to work
on strengthening the core muscles and
also to add in some cardio workout 2
plus belly fats there will be three
exercises for each circuit and we want
to end with a cardio workout just to
bring your heart rate up for each
workout it will be 40 seconds work with
20 seconds to rest in between
[Music]
so let's get it down onto the mat all
right so make sure you're firmly seated
on your bum with your toes pointed
forward about hip-width apart okay what
I want to do is support your upper body
on your elbow this is going to be the
first workout which is V crunch all
right so what I'm going to do is push
through the mat lift your leg straight
up crunch just like a v-shape bring it
back down and bring it back up
okay and it will be 40 seconds work
let's go up and back down point your
toes up and down remember with core
exercises
it's not about rushing the workout but
rather it's about engaging your core
muscles
feeling your core muscles and just
taking it slow because sometimes the
slower you do the workout the more you
will feel the work on your core good up
and down beginners if this is too tough
you can always start by bending your
knees a little bit and bring it back
down just about two inches off the floor
and up and back down okay so keeping
your chest up and straight do not hunch
good all right now plank let's go into
plank rock okay so again forearms elbows
on the floor stand
keep your back flat and what a way to do
is rock forward and back forward and
back that's it okay keeping your body
and your back straight throughout let's
go forward and back type in your core
muscles really engage the core and walk
forward and back keep your neck in a
neutral position and just look down good
breathe in through your nose and breathe
out through your mouth
keep going breathe in and breathe out
good really suck your belly in - your
core muscles keep going right back okay
so do not arch or do not dip your back
straight back and forward and back good
now cardio blaster okay the third
workout will be a cardio blaster jumping
jacks simple yet a very effective
workout to drive your heart rate up so
start with your feet shoulder width
apart toes pointed forward and just step
out step in okay all right nice and easy
this is your first circuit take it easy
breathe in through your nose breathe out
through your mouth
whoo find your rhythm pace your
breathing good keep going
these are breathing very nice okay
keeping your knees soft and slightly
bent throughout good straight answer
reach both arms straight up and you will
feel the work on your shoulders as well
as your back good keep going last five
seconds and we want to repeat the entire
circuit once more and brick okay back
down onto the mat okay V crunch again
remember point your toes
support your upper body with your arms
do not sink your chest in keep your
chest up throughout okay ready and let's
go straight up and down nice and control
up and down this will really work on
your lower abs good and up whoo
point your toes straight up and back
down nice I can feel my ABS shaking and
my legs shaking as well and that is
absolutely fine that means your muscles
are doing the work down and up up and
down
keep going
up and down good whoa breathe out as you
come up okay and let's get into plank
rock right elbows and shoulders should
be in line and your arms should be
straight okay if this is too difficult
you can always start on your knees all
right
su progress get onto your toes so let's
go plank rock forward and back and
remember do not look straight okay gaze
gently on the floor keeping your neck in
a neutral position keep going forward
and back strong shoulders as well okay
tighten your core suck your belly in
view the burn on your core muscles your
core is not just your abs it's a
obliques as well as your lower back last
few more seconds
forward and back keep going and now
let's get up all right
jumping jacks breathe in breathe out and
let's get into jumping jacks okay let's
push yourself for 50 seconds let's go
find your rhythm okay the better you are
at pacing breathing the longer you will
us through the workout all right so
remember don't just let your arms flap
everywhere have control drive it
straight up and back to the side of your
body stir it up and to the side and just
breathe last 20 seconds come on let's
speed it up up and down up and down
nice strong body strong core the end of
your first circuit five more seconds
keep going strong arms strong legs and
rest it out okay take a one-minute rest
I'm going to explain to you the next
three exercises the first is going to be
knee tucks
so again lie on your mat support your
upper body with your pumps and all I
want to do is drive your knees in close
to your chest to drive it straight out
in and straight out okay that's the
first workout the second workout is
going to bleed plank up down so again on
your elbows push it straight up bring it
back down and push it straight up and
the final workout which is your Cuddy
blaster is going to be a wide squat - a
crisscross wipe crisscross wide okay got
that
so three exercises first will be knee
tucks second plank up down and a cardio
blaster to finish the circuit and we
want to repeat it twice
alright 20 seconds left if you need to
drink some water wipe your sweat and
just get your body ready for circuit
number two ten seconds left make sure
that your pumps are firmly on the floor
supporting your upper body okay and
ready
toes point is straight and let's go knee
tucks close to your chest crunch your
abs upper and lower abs bring it in
straighten it in and out good drive it
in Oh as much as you can okay let's go
keep going tuck it in breathe out and
breathe in breathe out and breathe in
good half we're there keep pushing it do
not rush through the workout okay slow
down the movement and you will be
engaging your core and hip flexors even
more last one more
okay now let's get into plank up down
this will work on your core as well as
your upper body alright short breather
ten seconds left
make sure that your shoulders and your
elbows are both in line so do not go too
far forward ready up let's go push it up
and back down
minimal movement on your hips okay
keeping your car strong minimal movement
on your hips do not sway your hips side
to side this is wrong push it up tighten
your core and back down and not the
opposite side up and back down good
straight up down straight up and dump
very good last ten seconds back down
straight up whoa who's with me
stay strong up and now let's get up onto
your toes okay
so white squad to work on the outer part
of your glutes as well as your inner
thighs okay and hop right back in with a
criss cross ready step white let's go
cross it and now the opposite side all
right good
forty seconds down cross good if you
want to bring your arms down that's you
hop
very nice work on your legs feel the
burn on your glutes back down cross over
stab wide okay make sure that you're
stepping white good last ten seconds
wide
criss-cross that's two more
that's one more and rest okay back it
down now that your licks are a little
bit sore the next knee tucks should be
tougher so breathe in breathe out
catch your breath let's get ready
supporting your upper body with your
palms okay and let's go in and straight
out in and out
good nice and easy keep the pace steady
nice and steady
breathing through your nose breathing
out through your mouth
nice use the upper and lower abs few
more you are almost there last five
seconds last one more and plank up down
okay now let's get back down onto the
mat alright let's all start in a high
plank okay use this as your active
recovery but in a high plank and we want
to get into plank up down let's go down
and back up
down and up remember minimal movement on
your hips up push it straight up and up
keep your back flat
down and up down and up good strong core
strong upper body planks a really good
workout and you can do lots of different
variations up and good no finer cardio
blaster and that is the end of second
second if you find the jumping to be
challenging what you can do is start in
a white squat okay and just step in step
back out and remove the explosive
movement so down step in step back out
down step in and step back out okay as
you progress then get into a criss cross
down and up good always find your own
pace you are working with your own body
not someone else's body okay so listen
to your body
everybody has their own starting point
alright and the more consistent you are
with your workout the stronger you will
be good when I first started I could not
even run two minutes on the treadmill it
was tough but then you have to study
progress okay good take a one-minute
break grab some water if you need to
wipe your sweat we're moving on to the
third circuit okay
all right let's go through all the
exercises so the first will be criss
cross Caesars again support your upper
body with your elbows what I want to do
is just like V tucks but this time I
want you to criss cross just like a
season so k a pair of scissors that's it
second workout will be spider-man plank
the second workout will always be a
plank and this is going to work on your
bliss
so again high play crunch to the side
crunch to the side all right and the
final workout will be a cardio blaster
it's going to be new to squat so start
in a kneeling position I went to hop
into a squat back down and hop okay all
right let's start with the first workout
let's go see this up and down
alright straight up and back down good
and straight up as high as you can and
slowly back down okay
pointing your toes forward nice keeping
your legs as straight as possible down
close to the floor and back up okay you
don't have to go to white
just a small crisscross last one
and back ah all right
spider-man plank let's focus on your
obliques as I said your core it's not
just your abs your obliques and your
lower back as well so high point all
right let's go right elbow to right knee
okay and let's go right knee to the
elbow and the opposite side good
reaching through and straight back into
a plank this is not an easy workout all
right so find your own pace keeping your
body as still as possible feel your
obliques working crunch it and crunch it
nice driving your knee as close to your
elbow as possible keep going you're
almost there last few more and AH 20
seconds rest before our next cardio
blast all right so the next cardio blast
will be a new to squat if this is too
challenging what you can do is start in
a newly position and just step straight
up and back down okay
let's go choose your options that
straight up back down or from a new
explode into a squat back down explode
tighten your core into a squat so use
the strength from your core and also the
strength from your thighs and explore
and back down good again push it up and
down whoop my heart rate is skyrocketing
up and down and back up and back down
okay few more up down last one up and
down okay repeat the entire circuit once
more so let's get back down
whoa-ah it's not gonna be easy
but this is what it takes to work on
your core as well as the cardio to
blasts belly fat all right so let's go
crisscross straight up as high as you
can and slowly come back down
okay straight up and back down
good nice halfway there Oh keeping your
legs as straight as possible toes
pointed forward okay keep your chest up
last one let's bring it back down and
rest it out okay get yourself into a
high plank all right oh I can see my
sweat dripping straight onto the mat all
right let's get into a high plank this
is your shot
active recovery okay and we want to get
straight into spider-man plank okay
let's go knee to elbow knee to elbow
good breathe
and gaze gently on the mat breathe
strong
upper body strong core all working
together to support your body ten
seconds left let's go see your sweat
dripping remember like I've always said
that's your fat crying keep going last
one and last cardio blaster for this
circuit okay whoa catch your breath
breathe in breathe out okay let's get
back down onto the floor kneel to squat
all right five more seconds within
without choose your option if you do
have knee injuries then choose to just
step up okay down and step up choose
your option okay if not go all out
explode into a squat what I love this
workout it's such a good workout for
your car as well as your lower body and
it will really make your body burn lots
and lots of calories halfway there
you're doing strong three circuits
almost done one more to go
let's go look straight ahead
chest up and rest it off okay one minute
break okay if you really need to get
into a child's pose
and just bring your heart rate back down
okay take this time to breathe alright
I'm going to go through the final
circuit with you the first workout will
be Russian twist so again sit on your
bum choose your option okay we're doing
this without any weights so you can
place both heels on the floor and just
lean your body back slightly tap gently
just tap twisting your entire upper body
working on your obliques if you want to
challenge yourself then you can always
lift both legs off the floor and twist
alright next workout
plank hip dip so get into a low plank
and what I wait to do is dip your hips
side to side all right and we want to
end the workout with your favourite
exercise barbies yes you got it
burpees okay so let's get into position
let's start with the first workout which
is Russian twist working on your
obliques so choose your option to begin
with you can just lean back slightly and
just tap side to side okay as long as
you feel your core and your obliques
working to challenge your core even more
then lift your legs off and tap side to
side okay fine which works for you you
can start with your heels on the floor
and midway through lift your heels up
good tap side to side and just tap very
good keep going five more seconds keep
your legs straight okay do not rotate
your legs and good okay now plank hip
deep okay oh my strap is just dripping
through but I'm feeling really good I
can feel your burn and your soreness
okay stay with me this is your final
circuit all right plank hip dip let's go
left and right left
and right good keep going still working
on the obliques dipping your hips side
to side again do not Pike to high up
okay if you're doing this this is wrong
or do not arch your lower back so making
sure your back is flat
dip your hips side to side and through
the side of your abs working good tip it
side to side last five seconds two more
and you are done okay
cardio blaster let's give it a burpees
all right
find your option choose your option if
you want to do it without a hop that's
fine as well find what works for you
remember this is your final circuit so I
want to see all your energy let's go in
hop up back down and up good and keep
going get into a high plank okay
nice both fit in and jump as high as you
can
good only 40 seconds last few more
give me at least two more and last one
oh all right
breathe breathe and breathe one final
round so let's get back down onto the
floor we have a Russian twist okay oh I
am feeling sore tired everything you
name it okay so legs up and just twist
side to side if you want to find your
balance look at one point straight ahead
of you okay instead of rotating your
head so keep your head still find your
focal point and just twist your core
side to side okay twist keep going nice
last ten more seconds lick strong strong
core few more last five more seconds
whoa three two one oh my gosh whoa you
crazy amazing human being
ah two more exercises forty seconds each
and you're gonna give me a high five
right at the end of this workout okay
let's get down into plank hip deep let's
go
you're almost there stay with me
who left them right breathe in and
breathe out let's focus on your body
right now do not think I'll worry about
the time but rather focus on engaging
your core muscles focus on how your body
is feeling right at this moment you are
almost there okay listen to yourself
listen to your body find a strength
within you okay one final purpose you
got this you got this okay
forty seconds left you have done twenty
five minutes of work out with me and you
have only 40 seconds left
that's nothing okay let's stand up let's
get into burpees and let's hop straight
up good both licks in as high as you can
okay hop good if this is too tough stand
up and reach find your option everybody
needs a starting point you are only in
competition with yourself and nobody
else keep going push your limits get
stronger mentally and physically nice
see you sweat dripping that's your own
effort and nobody else
last one more and very very well done
huh all right now just take a deep
breath in breathe out and just bring
your heart rate back down okay
all right I want you to spend at least
five minutes to stretch your entire body
out keep yourself hydrated remember it
is very important to keep yourself
hydrated throughout the workout okay you
have done such an amazing job this
workout will work both on your core as
well as your cardio by driving your
heart rate up let me know in the
comments below if you are drenched in
sweat like me and if your core is on
fire okay give me a thumbs up share this
workout and challenge your friends do a
core and cardio workout for the next
four weeks and don't forget to subscribe
to my youtube channel if you haven't
done it and check out a lot more workout
videos fitness tips as well as healthier
recipes all the best